mesdames messieurs nous vous souhaitons
d'abord un heureux dimanche en famille
autour de votre petit écran de
télévision
et bien justement sur votre petit écran
de télévision vous en avez vu des
émissions cette semaine vous en avez vu
des événements des hommes des artistes
vous est-il arrivé de vous demander ce
qui se passe lorsqu'une émission est
terminée oui quand votre appareil 7,1
que se passe-t-il au delà de l'écran et
bien justement par exemple mardi mardi
vous avez vu un merveilleux jeune
pianiste aldo ciccolini dans l'émission
musique pour vous de lucienne bernadac
qu'at-il fait ce jeune pianiste une fois
qu'il a terminé de jouer pour vous et
bien c'est précisément ce que va vous
apprendre la première séquence de notre
émission
au delà de l'écran
m
[Musique]
et bien voilà l'émission est terminée et
on va sortir du studio des buttes
chaumont
voici lucienne bernadac la productrice
réalisatrice et voici sont invités au
revoir gérard soap qui est le
réalisateur de l'émission musique pour
vous où va-t-on aller voyons il faut se
détendre après cet effort on prend la
petite voiture est bien sûr on s'en va
prendre un pot comme on dit on s'en va
où
puisqu'on les napolitains ont ça va au
café napolitain vous allez voir ça dans
une seconde onu a doucement parce qu'on
est quand même un peu fatigués et on va
s'installer à une table en conversation
animée
regardez cette extraordinaire regarder
ces mannes virtuose qui pianote même
l'heure s'il n'y a pas de piano qui
pianotent sur la table il est vrai que
les mains sont pour aldo ciccolini un
moyen d'expression puisqu'ils les
napolitains
il parle avec ses mains voyez il se sert
de ses mains c'est vraiment un moyen
d'expression à tous les points de vue il
est né à naples il ya 34 ans et c'est un
appel qu'il a fait ses études musicales
par le conservatoire de naples avant de
remporter le prix marguerite long qui a
fait de lui un grand virtuose en route
pour l'hôtel avec un petit hommage en
passant à la musique bien française à
georges bizet et nous allons rejoindre à
d'aussi collini dans sa chambre d'hôtel
et pourriez-vous bien entendu dans cette
chambre rien piano il ne peut descendre
grand les hôtels où il ya un piano un
piano qui n'est peut-être pas
extraordinaire mais il n'a pas l'air en
effet très extraordinaire vous savez
c'est un peu comme le piano de charles
très de charles trenet le piano de la
plage de vieux plano de la plage
qu'est ce qu'il ya ça sonne faux il doit
se passer quelque chose
eh bien on va vérifier ça voyons voyons
qu'est ce qu'on va sortir de là
un animal non non pas un animal tout
simplement un métronome un métronome qui
va permettre de faire bonne mesure enfin
il le met en route
c'est assez difficile semble-t-il il le
met en route et la soirée va s'achever
comme elle a commencé par de la musique
encore de la musique toujours de la
musique
[Musique]
e
lundi soir vous vous souvenez vous avez
vu sur votre petit écran un homme
politique extrêmement célèbre un homme
politique qui a eu précisément 82 ans le
jour-même de son émission de 15 octobre
cet homme politique et perdre quatre
jeunes enfants dont le plus jeune a
d'ailleurs six ans et demi seulement cet
homme politique c'est paul rey nous
monsieur le président lundi soir à la
télévision
des milliers de téléspectateurs nous ont
vus comme moi même à la veille de votre
intervention à la chambre et je veux
dire que nous tous nous avons été
émerveillés que notre conviction de
votre jeunesse et de votre verre de vin
c'est pas l'avis de mes amis qui ont
déclaré que vous m'avez massacrés à la
télévision comment surtout le président
et il paraît que j'hésitais on m'a posé
des questions auxquelles je n'étais pas
préparée que j'ai fait une impression
déplorable c'est que vous assure que ça
n'est pas la vie des cités spectateurs
purent alors je m'incline devant la
volonté du peuple
en tout cas je crois que le lendemain
vous avez été satisfait d'autres
interventions à la chaux et je dois
reconnaître que la chambre c'est moi
très bienveillant le président nous
sommes aujourd'hui ici non pas pour
parler politique nous sommes réunis en
famille des centaines de milliers
famille vous regarde sans doute de
nouveau et vous vois dans un cadre
familier vous inviter à quel endroit dix
de leurs j'avais ma place des palais
bourbon à 100 mev dans la chambre
s'était bien commode pour les quarts de
nuit c'est ça donc vous rentrer très
vite après les séances rêve et vous êtes
chez vous mais je vois que si vous
marchez peu entre la chambre chez vous
vous avez beaucoup circulé dans la vie
car on entend des vues à peine 10 faire
qu'est ce que c'est que tous ces traits
rouges ce sont les endroits où je suis
allé dans le monde dans les salles
partie du monde c'était vous avez
beaucoup circulé malheureuse choisir un
demi-siècle wrecked de votre lieu de
travail selon elle si oui alors je vois
derrière vous derrière votre bureau
tu sais portrait je pense que ce sont
ceux des autres ce que vous aimez que
vous retrouvez après lycée en vous
laissant ses portraits à ses parts frais
voici la fille evelyne sire et des
enfants à connaître ici
mes garçons serge et voici le plus jeune
alexandre avait un côté la photographie
de ma mère alexandre si celui que j'ai
vu à l'entrée fait le lien quand on
sonne c'est nokia qui sont bien ouvrir
pour voir ce qui se passe dans le
cabinet de son père ce président je
voudrais demander ceci nous avons
certainement beaucoup téléspectateurs
d'un certain âge qui nous regarde en ce
moment qu'ils seraient heureux de
connaître le secret de cette vitalité
qui nous émérite n'a pas de secret c'est
une question de discipline
c'est à dire le matraquage et comment
votre journée va très souvent je
commence à se renvoyer sur le coup de 6
heures du matin a pris discrètement avec
pas réveillé ma femme
et puis je prends la radio anglais je
prends la radio français je fais la
culture physique à la radio oui je
prends les journaux les revues
françaises ou étrangères
et puis je bondis à la chambre la
commission des finances se venge la
préside
parfois je parle à la chambre vous avez
pu le voir et pour moi la trouvais que
ce n'était pas suffisant pour occuper un
homme
on m'a demandé les cartes mémoires à la
baisse par conséquent votre vie c'est de
vie travaillez vous pensez que l'un des
secrets de longévité c'est le travail
c'est le travail des jeunes même contre
les vacances je crois que quand un
moteur tourne à 3000 tours faut pas que
tu as tourné 15 cents tout parce que
vous avez commencé à connaître vous êtes
parlementaire que vous seriez vraiment
il y aura quarante et un ordre je suis
entré pour la première fois dans la
salle des sciences de la santé nasir 41
ans
et puis vous avez été député du sinn
secteur alsace d'abord puis le deuxième
7 heures du matin j'ai l'honneur de
représenter les paysans flamand c'est à
dire sans interruption vous avez été
parlementaire avec cinq ans
d'interruption 50 prison enfin à quoi
vous avez des condamnés à la prison evin
namor même à mort par monsieur hitler
c'est un des rares échecs de sa carrière
avant l'échec des filets c'est le
président un dernier conseil
alors sur le plan hygiénique si ça nous
ennuie pas qu'est-ce que vous conseiller
à nos amis pour garder votre oeuf leur
jeunesse de roger black aces culture
physique oui manger peut ne pas boire
d'alcool boire un peu de loi qui est un
des beaux produits de la france
et puis travailler beau
parfait et je vois vous avez enfin le
dernier secret alors ce secret il est
représenté dans votre famille par
beaucoup de personnes mais je crois que
c'est le plus jeune de vos fils qui va
venir à l'instant féliciter son papa
prend alors monsieur nous sommes très
heureux monsieur le président de vous
voir également le futur président
comment il s'appelle cet honneur
alexandre c'est plus alexandre études en
classe et toi qu'est large 6 ans et demi
et je crois que tu as la chance d'avoir
la propre moment de son père c'est à
dire ta grand mère qui a donné à la
famille
l'exemple de la longévité eh bien elle
est morte dans sa 99e à dire et j'espère
bien qu'avec les progrès de la science
nous allons vivre dix à quinze ans de
plus et vient de ce président c'est ce
que nous souhaitons pour notre ami ici
présents pour alexandre pour toute votre
famille et pour que vos amis et pour le
pays merci monsieur le président mais il
y à une émission que vous voyez très
régulièrement tous les mercredis soirs
c'est la loterie nationale
vous avez des chiffres des chiffres
défilent sur votre écran des chiffres
qui parfois vous laisse indifférent
mais avez vous pensé aussi que dans
certaines familles décrit sans pousser
ça y est on la regarde bien vite
égoutter si vous avez un billet voilà ce
qui se passe comme dans l'émission de
jacques armand telle époque je vais
traverser pour vous la porte du passé la
porte est tout bêtement collé contre le
mur mais mais où sommes-nous à paris en
devant le pavillon de flore mais
pourquoi parce que la loterie nationale
fut créé en 1933
à cette époque le billet entier valait
100 francs le gros lot était de 5
millions comme le temps passe
en 1960 le billet entier vos 2006
enfants léger et le gros lot a été porté
à 100 millions de francs l'egypte on
peut se procurer des billets un peu
partout et des dixièmes à chaque point
leur parent vite s'il vous plaît merci
madame
le tirage des tranches et hebdomadaires
sans compter les tranches spéciale que
se passe-t-il au delà de l'écran lorsque
la télévision a fait connaître les
résultats
le mercredi soir
200 choses l'une où vous n'avez par mes
billets et alors vous vous préoccupez
des résultats de la loterie comme de
votre première chaussette ou vous
possédez un billet et après avoir
vérifié plusieurs fois dans différents
journaux que la chance ne vous a pas
favorisés rien du tout l'entrée est bien
vous le déchirer en jurant qu'on ne vous
y prendra plus troisième hypothèse votre
10e et remboursables allez vous
encaissez les 300 francs qui vous sont
généreusement à faire mais non mais non
comme tout le monde vous l'échanger
contre un autre de la tranche suivante
autre éventualité votre dixième gagne un
lot important
vous vous rendez au siège de
l'organisation et maîtrise en pensant
quand je pense que si j'avais acheté le
billet entier je gagnerai dix fois plus
enfin c'est toujours ça 5 millions de
francs deux côtés même de francs léger
ça fait un beau paquet regardez
attention que je compte un peu 3 4 et 5
non portefeuille neuf fermes plus
en vain comble de la chance vous
possédez le biais entier qui a gagné le
gros lot alors un conseil dans ce cas
pas d'affolement
gardez votre sang froid avant tout de
l'organisation et de la méthode
un transport de fonds doit s'opérer dans
les meilleures conditions de confort et
de discrétion
essayer le plus possible d'être naturel
riou et de passer inaperçu notez
l'adresse pavillon de flore jardin des
termes tels pourra bientôt trois
[Musique]
et vous voici devant le petit chèque de
la forte voilà mademoiselle yvette
mademoiselle yvette qui va vous remettre
votre gros lot n'est allé voir les
formalités de règlement sont très simple
une petite vérification
bien sûr ce normal 100 millions de
francs
ça ne va jamais tenir dans cette petite
valise j'attends ah ouais si
mademoiselle yvette et voici votre
chèque
et oui au pavillon de flore on ne paye
pas en numéraire maintenant vous le
saurez et quand on est riche il faut
avoir dû qu'à attendre à beaucoup de cas
encore peter s'ils le font on est jamais
trop généreux et tant pis si vous n'avez
plus un sou sur vous quelle est
l'importance d'aller sur sept dernières
images tournées par jacques étiez vous
partirez à pied vers la gloire et la
féliciter et à vous tous
il n'avait pas gagné cette semaine bonne
chance pour la prochaine fois l'émission
qui m'a le mieux plus cette semaine
c'est l'émission de monsieur frédéric
rossif la vie des animaux
vous vous rappelez mais chez un petit
ami le petit singe qui se regarder dans
une glace
oui eh bien c'est ce que j'ai le mieux
joué mais cette semaine
c'est merveilleux la vie des animaux
mais je pensais que les petites filles
et petits garçons n'ont pas toujours la
chance d'avoir la télévision
maman m'a mené cette semaine une
exposition qui se tient à paris rue du
dragon
c'est l'exposition du premier grand
peintre américain qui est né à la fin du
xviiie siècle
il s'appelait john james audubon
regardez tous ces animaux comme ils sont
jolis et bien dessiné tenez voici
monsieur radote un portrait fait par son
fils
vous voyez qu'il n'y avait pas besoin de
télévision il ya cent ans pour admirer
les bêtes sauvages
ce que je me demande c'est comment
faisait monsieur ou de bonnes pour aller
peindre tous ces animaux à travers la
mairie aujourd'hui c'est tellement plus
commode avec une caméra
[Musique]
vous savez que je dis dans l'émission la
rue de la gaîté on a fêté le retour des
deux plus célèbres duettistes femmes de
ces dernières années les soeurs etienne
eh bien nous avons été voir dans le tohu
bohu des coulisses ce qui s'est passé
pour elle après l'émission
alors henri betty qu'est ce que vous
pensez de ces coulisses de bobino où
filmer nos amis jean tout vent et
corvées aillent à l'école liste de vos
vidéos des baisers des compliments des
embrassades des félicitations
le maquillage en fait c'est la vie
d'arsys le méli-mélo le plus
extraordinaire c'est amusant dans tous
les coins et quelque chose qui se passe
l'original il faut vous dire qu'on
prépare après une rémission une deuxième
émission kinescoper ah oui en effet et
alors c'est pour ça dès que l'affolement
de la première est terminée c'est
l'affolement de la deuxième qui
recommence en civil à vous la
reconnaissez attendait ah mais oui mais
oui mais voyons c'est fernand raynaud
déguisé en vampire qui prépare un numéro
avec jean nohain
ils sont recrutés on a tellement ri en
répétant le numéro que regarder ce pour
fernand les obliger à voter n'est pas
essentielle aux flics il va éclater de
rire c'est certain mais sa barbe va pas
tenir
bien des joyeux et la locomotive ça y
est 1 les soeurs etienne bravo
merveilleux formidable d'ailleurs on va
aller voir cl du 6e mais elle me disent
alors envie vite on va on va les prendre
un verre chez vous quoi et en effet
quelques instants plus tard elles ont
mis leurs manteaux ont accueilli les
voilà et nous arrivons chez moi voilà
mes enfants françois à me dire que
monique ma fille ma femme françoise
allez allez sabarat présentation
embrassades tout ce qu'on voudra
on a soif oui vous vous emballez boire
regardez lui il faut il faut vous dire
il faut vous dire que chez moi il ya une
porte secrète
voyez vous suivez bien
et quand le premier secours est terminée
et beya le deuxième et on évoque nos
vieux souvenirs du temps où
j'accompagnais chevalier monde et ça
c'est maurice toujours jeune ça c'est
moi un petit peu plus jeune encore
[Musique]
ça c'est mon fils françois je l'appelle
puis tous les regards d une chemise sur
le piano et avec les soeurs etienne on
se rappelle la première fois où je leur
ai joué c'est si bon cette chanson que
personne ne voulait et qui il faut bien
le dire fait maintenant le tour du monde
mentalement regarder tel père tel fils
vous voyez il bat la mesure
ma fille qui écoute est un musicien n'y
a pas d'erreur et comme c'est charmant
noceur etienne sont d'une famille de
cinq enfants je leur ai montré les
jouets que j'ai rapporté cette semaine
d'amérique de las vegas tenez regardez
ce motard oxyjet il y dix ans lui-même
de ces menaces révélées mécanique et
sept courses d'autos et les baisers des
coulisses se sont terminées le soir de
l'émission
comme vous le voyez avec des jeux
d'enfants aussi animé que naît dans les
coulisses de bobino vous avez vu hier
soir la nouvelle émission dans le régime
loi la prochaine vague
vous avez certainement été frappés par
ces deux jeunes et charmant
polytechnicien si sympathique qui se
trouve affrontés devant votre écran
eh bien ces deux jeunes gens sont
rentrés hier soir et je vais vous
montrer ce qu'ils ont fait quand on le
dit on était de retour à l'école
polytechnique vous les reconnaissez gens
de panafieu et françois chabas est
aussitôt l'émission terminée
ils ont quitté leur survêtement de sport
ils ont revêtu la tenue d'intérieur de
l'école le battle dress pour venir
retrouver les 300 camarades de leur
promotion
la promotion jaune car cette promotion
porte à millésime un père alors que les
300 jeunes portent la promotion rouge
il parcourt les couloirs de l'école
avant de gagner le cazères le cazères
voyez vous c'est un endroit où on
travaille est un endroit où on dort et
les camarades sont à qui les attendent
avec impatience et qu'on ne le vend des
jurys blanche en lisant
les voiles alors alors alors raconte
alors comment ça s'est passé
randy donc alors vous êtes ex-aequo et
là mes enfants je suis sûr que les
téléspectatrices voté pour kippour
chabane pour panafieu chabane lui veut
un petit peu goûté leur relaxe sur le
but nous soigner ou le buste c'est le
lie à polytechnique
ce nom vient d'un général le général
bunus qui a commandé l'école et qui a
donné son nom à celui qui l'a inventé et
pendant que chabane se relaxe au dessus
de lui le clac
le clac c'est le bicorne célèbre become
de la tenue de gala et la tangente
c'est-à-dire l'épée veille sur son repos
ne croyez pas que polytechnique on se
contente de s'allonger sur délire élevé
les souris blanches quand on travaille
on travaille même beaucoup on travaille
tout le temps on travaille dans les
amphis en arrivant les casernes
travaillent dans les salles 2010
création
on travaille aussi à la bibliothèque
crédit biotech coûte 280 mille volumes
et 1000 publication attendent les élèves
une bibliothèque qui compte aussi des
ouvrages magnifique quelques se vident
truffes qui a appartenu au secrétaire de
catherine de médicis et sous l'oeil de
monge fonda l'école en 1793 où le héros
comptant les étonnants uniformes portés
par leurs anciens depuis 1804 année
l'école explique polytechnique chaire
andré gilbert a été heureux de vous
retrouver hier soir à la télévision
et après l'émission je vous assure tous
vos amis évoqué beaucoup de souvenirs
alors je voudrais vous demander au delà
de l'écran à votre bureau
qui êtes-vous andré gillois mois ya 30
ans que je fais de la radio et vous eh
bien je vais vous étonner mais en effet
bien qu un peu plus jeune que vous avant
vous c'est pas possible
en 1924 et vendent n'apporte la preuve
ici car vu fait une émission qui était
je crois le premier appel à la
générosité du public en faveur d'un
vieux poète qui se mourait qui
s'appelait maurice duplessis et vais
amener jean cocteau devant le micro et
il a lu cette lettre que j'ai retrouvées
pour demander de l'argent pour maurice
duplessis
alors vous êtes mon aîné radiophonique
un petit peu mais à ce moment là j'avais
du reste dans la poche une autorisation
gouvernementale de monter un poste
émetteur le rates quoi vous même moi
même à 20 ans mais oui parce qu'on les
donne à n'importe qui à ce moment
et personne ne voulait faire la preuve
c'est xavier annonc e banking j'ai été
sollicité et qui m'a dit quand est-ce
que tu t'occupes pas de choses sérieuses
ex alors je me suis occupé de choses
sérieuses à ce moment là j'ai publié les
oeuvres de jules renard et courteline
j'ai en particulier trouver le journal
inné de jules renard dont voici la
première édition
courteline vela sa photo je place devant
celle de mon épouse excusez moi et j'ai
publié ses offres complètes et puis
ensuite nous nous sommes retrouvés à la
radio et c'est donc vers 34 ans 34 et
alors là j'ai sollicité comme vous même
un certain nombre de gens de participer
des émissions il est miraculeusement
retrouvé quelques lettres
voici une lettre d'andré gide qui
acceptaient de passer devant le micro
une lettre de bergson une lettre de
colette une lettre de l'ivi brûle et
même une lettre du maréchal pétain qui
acceptaient que de présenter mes
auditeurs l'évocation radiophonique de
la bataille de verdun
et puis les temps ont changé et nous
nous sommes retrouvés à londres dans une
petite maison dont je dois d'avoir le
dessin ici et on faisait aussi de la
radio et qui m'a valu une lettre que
dont je voudrais citer un passage parce
qu'il est amusant c'est une lettre du
général de gaulle dans laquelle il m'a
dit entre autres le monde tout
naturellement à la formule de l'ancien
grand guignol après un acte de drame un
de comédie alors je voudrais revenir à
la comédie et tiré en de mes souvenirs
ça c'est au sial un petit souvenir de
londres c'est un cendrier qui m'a été
donnée là bas et ceux ci c'est une boîte
dans laquelle il y à un film tiré de
l'émission que je faisais en 1934 poste
parisiens qui s'appelait la demi-heure
en correctionnelle dans laquelle jean
nohain avec des cheveux
claude dauphin petit se nomme et
marguerite moreno avec tout son talent
de faisait cette émission au canevas et
on en a fait un film
et le voilà et hier soir au journal
télévisé vous avez certainement été très
émue par la séquence consacrée à madame
odette du lac la veuve de dulac qui fut
le compagnon de raimu dans le rôle d'une
carte fixe dans marius les lecteurs de
télé c
jours m'ont chargé de vous remettre ce
chèque qui ont permettra je l'espère de
réaliser votre voeu le plus cher
eh bien oui espérons que ce chèque
apportera un peu de douceur à la pauvre
dame du lac qui habite cette pauvre
maison la maison d'une artiste qui fut
fêté un choyés c'est la triste retraite
d'une cigale une retraite si étroites
qu'on ne sait plus où se mettre
c'est dans ce cadre minable colette du
lac vie au milieu de ses rennes où sont
les fastes d'antan sur les succès les
bravos les soirées avec raimu avec les
joyeux marseillaise marius est césar
pourtant oled du lac et rester coquette
avant d'aller travailler aux champs pour
ses voisins pour gagner quelques francs
ou la voyez qui brosse soigneusement ses
cheveux
[Musique]
on a celle qui fut la grande artiste
choyé la grande artiste fait et qui va
tristement sur la route les ardeurs du
soleil ont remplacé maintenant les feux
de la rampe
[Musique]
et hier soir
aussitôt après l'émission du journal
télévisé nous sommes allés dans sa
maison de marnes-la-coquette retrouver
marie chevallier qui a bien connu du lac
et odette du lac
oui en effet j'ai connu du lac
ça devait être en 1905 je crois à l'éden
de saint-etienne un music hall de
province qui avait de très bon spectacle
et du lac était un comique troupier très
jeune à cette époque-là moi-même de
avoir 16 ou 17 ans quelque chose dans ce
genre là et lui même était un homme
jeune de 21 22 ans très bons artistes
très bon comics et en même temps un très
brave un de ces artistes qui ne s'occupe
de personne d'autre que d'essayer de
bien faire leur travail croisette
elle était serveuse dans ce sens la
grande brasserie qui à tonnay à l'éden
de saint-etienne et ils se sont
rencontrés elle était très belle très
belle fille très propre très bien ils
sont tombés amoureux l'un de l'autre ils
se sont mariés et c'est une histoire qui
tout simplement à durer toute une vie
par la suite du laki a fait de deux très
bons de très bonnes performances dans
l'est dans les films de pagnol avait une
très gentille situation et sa femme a
toujours été près de lui comme la
mignonne et modeste serveuse qu'elle
était au début de leur union
tout ce qu'on peut dire c'est que si on
les connaissait on était forcés de les
aimer et de les respecter tous les deux
[Musique]